[Music]
we're turning Monday night on CBS
beginning from the Big Bang Theory and
right away a big question will get
answer would you marry me
we literally pick up in matching outfit
the hair due to the hair clip we're
right there he's on one knee one moment
please
really you're gonna answer that right
now
what's Leonard I don't want to be rude
so will Amy actually say yes to Sheldon
Oh everybody in the supermarket has an
opinion about it that was my experience
everywhere I went people were like she
says yes right I said I don't know I'm
on vacation fans aren't the only ones
dying to know if amy accepts the writers
like to keep the cast in the dark too
they're constantly doing things that you
never saw coming
I feel like she'll say yes to but that
may not be what they have in mind I was
having lunch with dr. Nowitzki and she
kissed me yes I'm sorry it's a really
fun episode then we just kind of watch
everyone's drama unfold while doing yoga
and drinking wine you get to eat cake
ate cake in this episode and after 231
episodes Haley's earned if you could
give some advice to younger Kaylee 11
years ago what would you say to her um
get used to those stairs in the
apartment set cuz they're gonna get a
lot harder to climb by season 8 9 10 11
oh and also like my eyes are getting
worse it's like I'm reading scripts I
used to be oh so cool now I'm like
bringing it up but I can't see anything
oh by the way the cast is already signed
on for season 12
[Music]
you